[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Salam alaikum wa rahmatullah better care
to brothers and sisters and dear friends
welcome to the knowledge corner as you
guys can see there is the corner and
inshallah we do have some knowledge one
of my dogs I always I always try my best
and that's well known for well anyways
Roble sisters welcome to this corner
shallow we're here with Chef Mohammed of
Manish a lot and also we have chef
Mohammed our owner is well in this
specific corner where we will be
discussing and talking about your
questions that you ask us and repos up
to the people of knowledge and this is
something very important for us to do as
laymen like myself to not talk about
matters that I'm not qualified to and
stick to my lane is very important was
to be a bit polynomial of youngsters
beat myself you know I suppose I have to
myself is wanna say no know your limit
state here limit and this is the reason
why we have the knowledge corner because
we can come to the people of knowledge
ask them and let them tell us what we
should rather than the opposite way so
what we're going to do is is Charla we
have we're gonna go through a few things
you have restructures we'd like to be
structurally Sharia so we're gonna go
through is the clothing for men and
women we're gonna discuss obviously
we'll stop with the mints
stop the men were mentions a few
principles to do with the men directly
and then after that you can mention a
few principles concerning clothing of
the woman Shanta there's a lot to
therefore there's a lot of you know yeah
certain things apply to both and
examples as what we're gonna talk about
briefly about men's clothing how it
should be woman's clothes and how it
should be and then we're going to try to
talk about more about maybe branding and
we might even mention it with examples
with understanding save you know maybe
it's gonna be in go free how I leave it
you clear so we mint a few principles to
do with many Sean Seiler
then this is principles that I will
mention Charla principles that the
majority of the folk are the majority of
the scholars a few agree upon and there
are left or a difference of opinion
within some of them and I'll mention
insurance I'll have very briefly been
there now the first principle is to do
with silk and gold obviously for men
these are principles concerning
ferments hard-on for them to wear
clothing that has silver and gold in it
worse for the woman it's permissible for
them to wear this some of the folk are
the scholars of such as the Hanna Villa
and this is the main opinion on Hannibal
and others state that there are certain
exceptions for men such that if there
are four fingers worth of silk and it's
permissible from together in their
clothing there could be a medical reason
for this etc as was done by some of the
Sahaba and so that principles connection
there yeah so basically if some kind of
medical condition to wear is well yes if
they have to weigh like a lot of
clothing purely of silk then for a
medical reason before a had a need it's
really neat and they can do so other
than that then it's permissible to have
with in uniform amounts silk about this
much along so hard war due to medical
reasons the second principle is to do
with covering the outer covering the
outer now I'll mention specifically for
things to do this the first thing is the
outer or the private area of men now the
form of that hip agree that the private
area of a men is from the belly button
to the knee from the belly button to the
knee now this is the hadith and it is
authentic but some of the folk AHA
especially specifically the Hanna fear
they state that the the the knee is not
included within it the knee is not
included within the derocker now of
course the difference of opinion amongst
this regarding the belly button and
regarding the knee etc etc believe that
there's no need to go through that
shelters second thing is to do with the
face no that's a very popular question
here are the thighs part of the outer or
not now the first part out or not now
the form of the hip for me that I
generally agree that the thighs are part
of the outer part of the outer you have
any wire narration from a Muhammad the
method is not this narrations the other
narration that is but is it a wire from
imam ahmed that stays the firstly the
thigh is not from the outer okay and
some of the photo you know most of the
method I have chosen these specific are
chosen the specific opinion said no
audibly maraquita kadhi the famous judge
may Allah have mercy upon him he chose
his opinion and others check with Amy in
remote island nowadays he mentioned this
is
his favorite opinion as well so that my
said it's best to be safe Charles now
there's best for so it was on the side
of caution the ATO that something is a
and safer for us especially what
concerns our our Dean
so the third issue concerning the
principles for men is the issue
concerning clothing that is tight now
some of the Fokker Hollis consider its
her aren't we're closing that is tight
for a man for a woman there is agreement
in this to do with a journey
non-relatives okay
but as fully man there's a difference of
opinion some say that it's completely
hard on clothing it's tight like for
example these trousers that you're
wearing accurately describes you like
the Malachy on the other hand they have
quite a middle part this would be view
the tightest like because I'm I'm
sitting down so for example I just stand
up if I can show you as you can see it's
it's tight but when I'm sitting down
friend and this a question I was gonna
ask you it's when I'm for example when
I'm sitting down because this falls on
the leaf or something it looks like that
so when I'm standing it's it's quite
loose them so of course the Medicare
they opinion that it's it is rather than
being Haram it's kuraha and this is for
clothing that does two things it
actually describes the outer but
specifically and this is the second
thing it describes the private parts
okay now many of the focus this is hard
on completely I said that it is Cara
this particular case and it's better
than on the South quadrant Charlotte on
the fourth thing is the issue of whether
or not clothing is they call it Shaffer
fur meaning see-through or not okay now
the folk are the majority of them if not
all of them state that if clothing is
see-through and it's Haram most describe
the aura so that's clear answer on this
these are the main things to do with the
aura of a man okay
the second or third principle which I
think one day you know cause a lot of
confusion recently is the issue of the
shampoo the issue of wearing clothing
that either resembles the Kafar you know
resembles moon no woman is clear maybe
some law isn't prohibited wearing the
clothing that or that resembles the
clothing of a woman so that a man
imitates a woman and likewise they
reverse but a woman imitates a man you
know so that's clear but the issue of
touchable awaring the clothing of the
Kafar is an issue in which yes there is
a lot of yeah no it's
a lot of confusion about mile of course
of course we know that mr. for loss of
Allah how do you thought never it's an
everyday would meant to share but have
you home in for who I mean home
whosoever resemblance a person and he's
like them it's important to understand
that this resemblance is to do their
religious clothing their religious
clothing clothing that is specific to
them so for example if you put on the
religious clothing of a certain group of
non-muslims then that is to Shabbat and
that is Haram so is there a difference
so for example let's say what a nun
wears what Nonnie a nun or a priest or a
Jewish person a Buddhist person a Hindu
no is this the same thing as someone
wearing an England shirt which has a
cross on it something that relates to a
deity that was worshipped before are
these two same thing for they separate
so as we said wearing clothing specific
to a specific religious group yeah that
identifies them and it's specific to
them or their religion is harm it's
Haram specifically wearing a cross now
there is a near consensus amongst the
folk AHA yeah that wearing a cross is
haram some have even gone further to
state that it is an act of major cover
and you find this on cloth or Islam and
you find many other yeah a strong
discussion on this but I didn't hate him
who's a famous chef a scholar and others
okay so now the question would be would
be to do clears analogy on the cross and
other religious symbols as well that are
specifically against religious groups if
this symbol is against something
specific to them and it clearly
identifies their religion then that
would take the same ruling I will take
the same eunuch however I think we are
getting are things that are not specific
to their religion anymore anymore it's
not identifiable as means something
specific to their religion anymore okay
okay which is subject to their that goes
back to their oath that goes back to the
customs and understanding or mean for
customs or from the customer okay we
have a principle in major principle in
the Sharia which says a little from her
camp all item hakama that we take into
consideration the customs of the people
where the Sharia has allowed it to take
into consideration okay not every issue
should be the certain issue the Sharia
has a lot of why because it hasn't
defined it it's left it open okay so I'm
didn't come to destroy the cultures of
people it came in fact to realign the
cultures with Allah so Allah intended
with now
and I was going back to hire him as I
mentioned for Tilbury
he discusses the hadith of Barabbas and
we shouldn't be somewhere in Salem
commanded them with a certain number of
things and he prohibited them with a
certain number of things and one of the
things is Alma throat alhambra now Anna
Mae Thornton Tamara is literally like a
cushion a red cushion that would be
placed underneath the saddle you know
not horse and we place underneath so I
was discussing the reasoning behind why
was this made prohibited and he said it
could be made prohibited due to a a
muscle I had done urea something that's
specific to this world okay not
necessarily the religion okay I mention
a number of things or he said it could
be due to a religious reason a religious
reason and he mentions that that
religious reason does not necessarily
apply now so therefore therefore if we
take that then this was something
specific to a certain religious group of
the past it is no longer specific to
them anymore therefore a little module
for the sole kuraha it is not makrooh at
all to use this - under - okay so it's
something that is specific to a person
this is what I want to highlight here
okay okay specific to a religious group
and this changes from time and place and
persons well and it's changed them
basically depending on the culture okay
okay so say for example we have a
clothing and it has a certain symbol on
it okay
now there'll be two questions to answer
firstly it's this symbol an actual
symbol of the a religion of part of old
or not if it is then we could say yes it
is Haram
why Valkyr so analogy on the cross okay
but if we say the symbol there is no
specific symbol to actually relate this
back to for example the cross or any
religious group okay then we would say
it depends on the earth it depends on
the culture it could be that something
may have religious connotations to it in
the past but it no longer has any
religious connotations to it anymore
therefore it is a it is not Haram to
where it isn't it is not counters
resembles look for say for example like
like and this what I mentioned about the
symbol applies there okay this is not
much clusters to really investigate
these things that's what this goes back
to the people
for example founders of the company etc
however if we say that if there was a
clear symbol for example of the goddess
of victory yeah
Nike or something I'm not sure it was a
clay symbol of her and this is what was
used in the past and we would suggest
you can do analogy on the cross to make
it harm and this is a valid opinion yeah
but if you say there is no clear symbol
of it okay and therefore subject to our
condition it is not associated with any
particular age group so therefore to say
it's Haram it's very difficult to say
that but I must say that my dear brother
may bless to agenda that this is an
opinion that in which there is valid
difference of opinion some of the early
amar has said it is Haram
we have to respect that of course and
some likewise I said it is jaw is
permissible to wear it indeed what I
have just mentioned we have to respect
that as well understand this is very
important why because we utilize a
principle which the ausonian the
scholars of the principles of have a
agreement on yeah which is a learning
curve you must sir English D hat what
does that mean
that means that you cannot say if it's a
valid difference of opinion I am more
correct than you and you are wrong and
this is a touch upon this is it's
actually the main reason why we're doing
this because we want to break down this
print this mentality of thinking that
there is an opinion over the other one
on my opinion against yours because what
it does is it causes the youngster
specifically those who they don't know
the basis of their religion fighting
each other based on this thing and this
behavior of no this is the opinion and
that's that opinion and you should go
and do this this is the mentality that
we're trying to get rid of you know and
nurture the youngsters suggest an and
respect each other's opinion then say no
this is the opinion and you must do this
absolu so that's one of the reasons why
we're doing is actually one of the main
reasons why I wanted to do this is not
to give people like I said before
there's another opinion and we totally
respect that I respect for us to not
respect it shows our ignorance it shows
that we're not implement in this
principle of course exact and it shows
actually lack of knowledge because if
you had some collagen and this today you
will understand that there is a
difference really you know and this
shows importance of a solution
essentially what is it it's a process to
understand the Sharia to understand fear
not only that but to apply it if you
have to apply it and this is what we
call a cosmonaut it is very important
powerful soul if you
and essentially applying a ruling on the
worker or the reality of the our
modern-day yeah it's something that is
subject to HD had usually had me
independently reasoning it may be right
it also may be wrong exactly it is not
the truth it we cannot say Allah has
said this or the rest of us our son has
said this or there are centers so we
can't say that there is a valid
difference of opinion on the matter
there is an opinion that they say look
it's Haram and there's a period that say
look it's not because it's something
that we use on a daily basis and it's
not just with Naik this is with Honda
this is with even the England shirt
because there is a cross on it for
example the English shirt this can be
with Mondays Thursdays Fridays with the
words that you utter however no you see
cross no different you see because we
mentioned before that cross there is an
a consensus amongst the folk AHA that
wearing a cross is Haram some have even
gone further so that's not okay that
that's still that religion still alive
and it's okay for something that isn't I
believe this is where the discussion
should be but that being said it's a
great area it's a great area and we have
to instill also into our brothers and
our sisters the concept of what are what
is what the concept of water is that you
leave something that may harm okay mmm
leave it yeah you want to be on the safe
side yes meaning that you know my Deen
is more beloved to me than buying this
particular merchandise so I want to
leave it in this case okay why why can't
we say why don't people do that with
Naik or be a Honda Honda's there's a lot
of things that fall into this where do
we draw the fine line because we can say
people because they okay we're using
that principle how could I go with the
other pinion which said it's permissible
and not go with the one that says Haram
you see it depends firstly this is comes
down to an issue if we say that there's
a valid difference of opinion area and
this is connected to another opinion
which is what do we do when we have more
than one fatso in front of us yes okay
we call this act 11:15 what do we do now
I personally count it when I reach this
measure and many years ago that there is
over 15 different opinions well and what
a person should do in this particular
case so really what is so many opinions
in opinions for the two opinions and
precisely
so what do you do some see how that
something you do now the opinion I chose
is the opinion for goofy which says that
you take the opinion of the person or
the mufti who you trust to things you
trust his knowledge and you trust his
level of taqwa you trust is a burden
that he's a person who shares our last
panel to other then you've done was
obligatory upon you a large analysis
vessel indicating come to me Italian ask
those of knowledge if you do not know so
you've done what's the point
other say other things some of the
school is sense or valid opinion some
that say you should take the hardest
opinion the harshest opinion on you mmm
for fear of not falling into it some say
you could you should take the easiest
opinion whatever is easy for you take
that there's a number of different
opinions so this is definitely this from
this opinion fact I would say many of
those who follow this thing you
shouldn't depend on two things firstly
the talk of a person and also what did
you say was the taqwa and the knowledge
of okay butterflyfish a Kaufman it was
good it was actually much already I hope
you give it inside to the people who's
gonna speak about the sisters clothing
as well but I think we're very limit at
the time and we don't want it to go over
time but it's a very important topic yes
is you know too extreme to do it sisters
clothing it's important that we mention
everything goes to show you really dealt
with this issue yes we can cover the
next conversation I think I may have
missed call to the Hannah fear right at
the beginning when discussing the outer
between the men and out of alpha man
between the belly button and the knee
okay so the majority of the scholars
view that the belly button Denis is not
part of the Jolla
enough you yes it is part of the other
especially hope you guys have understood
it clearly inshallah and got the advice
that's needed each other so it's up on
you now to take that knowledge and say
you know what I'm either gonna up
staying from it or there's a valid
opinion I'm just going to wear it so
that's totally up to you we've given you
the knowledge a balanced knowledge
coming from two angles that are valid
and that's a balance all you guys are
benefited and don't forget do not fight
with one another over these opinions
seriously that's exactly what we're
trying to abstain from there's a variety
of opinion and you say probably believe
that okay no problem
may Allah bless you you're my brother
don't hate people are boycotting each
other over this table it's a very very
exactly mr. head famous principle that
image not be called the innovator
between exactly I need anything your
profits finally we are told that certain
soon the things that we do we should not
do over if I brought if I'm fasting and
you invite me about your my brother's
right overcomes the soon action I'm
gonna do and you're boycotting your
brother over something that's difference
of opinion anyways BOM sisters
assalamualaikum from the knowledge
corner for me and sheikh mehmet oz man /
- next time assalamualaikum
warahmatullah ver here too